andrew i'm curious from your perspective
you've cop you've now seen
my out of the side of the world on the
entrepreneurial side
and the political world i mean how do
you get
how do we get government and
entrepreneurs
working together more effectively
to solve these issues well you know i
love what you're trying to do on core
because i think a lot of it
is that entrepreneurs are often
attracted to
areas where they they feel like they're
going to be able to operate
um uh more freely and efficiently
and then if you hit a highly highly
regulated zone then all of a sudden
you're like oh wait and then some
entrepreneurs like you are like willing
to you know
like swim through the muck and figure
out okay like what can i do in one of
these
and sometimes there's a great
opportunity in the highly regulated zone
in part because the regulations have
provided kind of like a mode of
discouragement
like i i worked in healthcare software
in the mid 2000s and i used to start
joking that healthcare is where good
ideas go to die
because because like a lot of the
practices
aren't super um
rational or efficiency minded and the
measurements are spotty at best
and so you wind up having people adopt
solutions based upon other criteria
um so so that there's there's a massive
opportunity here man i mean what you're
doing is awesome i think
uh on the political side i do think that
we have to figure out which regulations
are holding us back at this point
because there are a lot of rules that
made sense when you drew them up
and they they had a fine purpose but
then in terms of the impact
like it's a double-edged sword and then
we didn't undo that rule
and then we then made another whole uh
matrix of rules on top of that one
that'll like spit on top of it then
everyone's looking around
like that that's pretty much what's
going on but i guess is there a way that
you can like
change the culture of that internally i
mean because some of it's the rules but
a lot of it comes down to the culture of
the people that work
for like you know for the for the
government agencies right where
there isn't necessarily there's a
distrust of the private sector
number one which is probably fairly
warranted given some of the players in
the market today
and then there's also this culture of
fear of trying something new because no
one wants to get fired
so how do you create a culture where the
people who do
implement these policies and these rules
like
want to find ways to work with
innovators and be more innovative as a
government
well so so government bureaucracies have
a number of features
that make sense in their context but do
not necessarily make sense in terms of
pushing the envelope and some of the
issues you're talking about
so uh they're they're highly uh
they're highly regulated themselves uh
they're you know like each
worker tends to have like a whole set of
rules that that are
um constraining what they can and can't
do
they're built for very very long-term
continuity
um and so there are a lot of folks who
um who would be better suited frankly to
doing like a certain
uh tour of duty within government i
talked to a guy yesterday who like
worked in government for for eight years
and he was a great guy and it
accomplished a lot
um but he pretty much said like i did my
tour of duty
and you know and i think that that's
fair and but and then but then there are
people that you know the
but the organization generally is built
for like multi-decades-long continuity
and so you have people that
um operate in that time frame and then
if you show up and we're like hey let's
like do it get all the stuff done in 10
months they're like
10 months like i've been here for 10
years and i'm going to be here for 10
years more
and so you know don't necessarily yeah
yeah you don't need to
to be that gung ho and one organization
that does a great job of this that you
know i think
um we can get lessons from is an
organization called code for america
that enlists various people who are
engineers in codingtown and says look
like solve this
government-based issue and you know and
then you can return
uh you know to the industry um uh
there's also like the u.s digital
service
that that um does things at the federal
level
uh oh you'd love it so remember
healthcare.gov
[Music]
so when when the launch had problems uh
a group of techies led by
a guy named mikey dickerson from google
came in and uh patched and fixed the
website in real time it was like very
big deal
and then they stuck around to try and
fix other things
web related and tech related and so they
had a workforce of
like the low hundreds in in dc
that they just went around consulting
with uh various
agencies being like hey like can we like
help you with something we fix things
and they ended up with this like massive
um backlog of projects because everyone
was like we would love your help with
with this thing so and and they
and and it also had a tour of duty
aspect because a lot of them were
techies who would join the us digital
service and then do a tour of duty for
like you know
um three or four years and then uh and
then cycle out
um so there there are things that i'm
optimistic about
i'm going to share an idea with you
encore that i'm going to give it to you
and then maybe you can
do it and it's actually if there's one
human who might be able to do it it
might be you
um as you'll you'll see what i mean in
just a minute so
so so far we've talked about what you're
working on uh in two of the big three
housing and healthcare and they're both
awesome
and so here's something in education
that i've long reflected on
so you know that i spent a number of
years
running what became the country's
largest gmat
prep service that helped get you know
thousands and thousands of people into
various business schools um and
uh and i was looking at that value
proposition it was like wow like a lot
of like why are these people
all heading to business school which is
like a very significant opportunity cost
and career sacrifice you know it's like
two years the tuition is
uh you know maybe extremely high like a
hundred ten hundred twenty two thousand
two hundred thousand dollars
like it's gone up a little bit so yeah
let's call it two 200 000. um
and and so i made a list of things that
motivate people to go
to get these uh to get their mbas um and
uh one was the credential for sure uh
it was the professional network
the personal network um to to some
extent
um like the book learning but i'm going
to suggest that that stuff's like
you know not that central the
consideration
um
[Music]
two-year spring break for two hundred
thousand dollars so that so
there is a pivot right there's a career
pivot involved it's like okay i'm in
this track and then i'm gonna
um get my mba and there's gonna be this
big career pivot
so then i i thought to myself and i said
okay could you provide the credentialing
the professional network the personal
network the career pivot uh like some of
the book learning
in a shorter time frame than two years
uh
and uh and so i was imagining something
that i you know like
i'd call it would be like the mckinsey
summer retreat
that's like three months everyone comes
together for this period instead of two
years it's three months
but then you you have an environment
where people actually develop real
relationships and friendships
and the thing is about the mckinsey
aspect is that i chose mckinsey because
i was like what's like a very big brand
name
that could actually have the heft that
would actually be competitive
with like the you know hbs of the world
or or whatever the programs are
um and so then i thought it's like could
you deliver
like something in like a three month
period at a fraction of the cost that
had a lot of the social elements the
credentialing elements the
networking elements and even like the
employer appeal elements
if you like it and then i thought like
wow
like what an opportunity that is because
there are all these young people that in
my mind
like are looking for certain things and
the nba is like a very luxe version of
it
and very expensive version of in a very
enormous opportunity cost it's like
could you compress it and deliver
a lot of the benefits i love it listen i
love it i love it
it's uh it's like a much smarter version
of an executive mba
i it makes me reminds me of an idea that
if you decide to ever get out of the
politics thing and come back to the
business world maybe you could start
because this is
something i've been wanting to do and
frankly on the capacity to do right it
was inspired
by a lot of the stuff that you've been
talking about around ai automation
how do we rescale the workforce provide
them with stability right
and so there is some period in this
transition between
automation coming in and people
fully being out of jobs right there'll
be a transition point where it happens
gradually for some sectors
i'm first the problem is today if you
lose your job that is also the point at
which
you need the most amount of financial
help you've just lost your job
and the point where lenders want to do
the least to help you
it's this really bad dynamic right
and so and the problem is as these jobs
go away it becomes harder and harder to
ever get back on your feet
and there's no real clarity on what to
do to get the new skills or what path to
take or what courses whether it's a
summer program like this or if you're
even more vocationally taking a
different type of program to get back in
the workforce
and so i had this thought of what if we
created like an unemployment lending
retraining program right so you lose
your job
you actually depending on your thing
qualify for an emergency set of funds
right and it is priced at a high
interest rate because you are a high
risk at that point however
it gives each person who takes out a
loan a
clear path towards reemployment that
they can use
they commit part of those funds towards
training and maybe those are provided
for free
every step of the way that they progress
their rates drop so it incentivizes the
de-risking of the
loan while providing people frankly the
clear path
to re-employment so you lose your job
during x we say you know what here are
the five paths that
actually could be you know most feasible
least feasible
etc based on your current skill set and
here are some emergency funds to get
back on your feet and
that is an incentive for you to go kind
of re-qualify and take those courses
to get rehired there's something here
it's rough but if anybody could pull it
off it's you
i love anything that helps smooth out
these transitions because as you know
like i don't think that
we're doing enough as a society to help
people manage these transitions
and uh you know and like you said the
path's actually very unclear for a lot
of people as to like what that next
opportunity would look like
uh you know a lot of it hinges too upon
um regions
where uh you know the economy's shifting
in a way that sometimes
the next opportunity for you like might
be
a few states away but right now like you
know you don't
recognize that that's the case
[Laughter]
yeah the in in theory the public sector
would be doing more in this direction
um and it's something i'm very
passionate about so i can see why you
raised it man
um something there yeah no and i like
the way your mind works too because
you're
you're trying to smooth over some of the
financial ups and downs and you're
trying to bring uh
you know like um like try and front load
the value it's like you see the value
that's going to happen when someone does
get that new job and then you're like
hey let's try and bring it forward to
like where they need it
[Music]
you